voici la rue la plus cool de la planète
selon le magazine international Time Out
avec ses restaurants ses bars et sa
piétonnisation en été la rue Wellington
symbolise le nouveau Verdun branché et
gentrifié plus jeune et multiculturelle
60% des électeurs sont francophones
le paysage politique changera-t-il lui
aussi
mais ça sent bon à Verdun François
Legault a visité la circonscription la
semaine dernière la CAQ met toute la
gomme pour faire élire Véronique
tremblayes qui s'ajoutent à tous les
jours il y en a encore qui vont
s'ajouter actuellement conseillère
municipal dans l'équipe de Valérie
plante elle promet des logements
abordables et une nouvelle école je
pense vraiment que je peux jouer un rôle
intéressant je trouve que c'est
important que Montréal soit plus
représenté elle avait flirté avec les
libéraux en 2016 pour être leurs
candidates puis finalement ils ont
choisi quelqu'un d'autre puis je
comprenais très bien le choix j'aime les
défis puis j'aime quand les choses
avancent et c'est pour ça que j'ai joint
la carte parce que je les trouve très
proactif dans l'île des sœurs où elle
habite un secteur surtout francophone
est plus riche de la circonscription
certains électeurs la critiquent ça
m'énerve facilement comme ça de
d'un parti à l'autre mais beaucoup
appuient la carte et son chef avant oui
j'étais libéral moi monsieur legou je
l'aime bien donc
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait fait une bonne
job donc pour l'instant je pense ça va
être mon choix les francophones on est
tout pour le 4 parce que le goût nous
ressemble c'est pas grave
en grande phrase
solidaire se voit aussi gagner Verdun
qui part en droit rappelle de plus en
plus le Plateau Mont-Royal sa candidate
est Alejandra Zaga Mendes la présidente
du parti Berdin c'est très très
diversifié moi je suis vraiment fière de
diversifier là moi même je viens
d'améliorer une grande je sens que on
peut connecter avec tout le monde même
les personnes anglophones et du Québec
c'est la loi Navy Robson
avec son doctorat en économie écologique
et les derrière l'ambitieux plan de
lutte contre les changements climatiques
proposés par le parti ici là on a un
accès aux fleuve à Verdun puis on le
sait à quel point c'est important de
protéger une auberge à quel point c'est
important lutter contre les ulottes
chaleurs son message rejoint les jeunes
en particulier un projet de société
middle avant puis surtout une réponse au
changement climatique je pense que
vraiment la vague orange est déjà
enclenché ici avez-vous peur de perdre
votre château fort mais moi j'ai donc je
suis à ma troisième élection aussi à
Verdun j'ai jamais rien pris pour acquis
Isabelle me lançons reste malgré tout
confiante d'être réélu pour les libéraux
c'est un grand village les gens sont ici
serrés et je pense qu'en sens là les
gens reconnaissent que mon travail s'en
est un de proximité comme ce midi là où
elle fait campagne dans une coopérative
d'habitation pour un nez parce qu'il me
fait le plus plaisir c'est quand les
gens disent moi là je te disais il y a
pas de couleur
son bilan comme député semble apprécier
parfois plus que son parti et elle
connaît les organismes elle connaît les
enjeux locaux étaient impliqué au niveau
d'hôpital de Verdun notre Isabelle on
l'aime tellement
avec me l'encens c'est bon ça on va le
garder le slaga Isabelle Melançon
l'avait remporté par 3600 voix dans
Verdun en 2018 devant Québec solidaire
et la CAQ ici jean-Sébastien Cloutier
Radio-Canada Montréal